hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now I have skipped the last one because
that one was caught what why why this
seems like actually this seems
ridiculously similar to an actual level
of Mario maker or Mario Super Mario soo
smart smart smart smart / maker smooth
snoopers mario bros smash smash whipper
snipper shimajiro's this seems very much
like that [ __ ] my dick
oh god wha okay Oh chica things are
going badly as per usually to use the
slate no I played live on the grump show
I did they pulled me on stage with very
minimal warning I wasn't told beforehand
that I was doing it it was just like
Danny came up on his site hey you want
to be on stage and I'm like okay I guess
I could jump over these but I'm gonna
take my time because patience is key on
everything that I do in this and when I
normally not do with the patient's doing
it usually done did end up me dead Ninh
snis yeah
please be mushroom because I keep losing
my chances no I'm not gonna go down
there just yet I know better
I'm smart doing the thing that's smart
yeah get out of here no wow oh God okay
nope yeah I'm gonna dodge you dodge like
that okay oh god no not what I wanted
lost it again why did I lose it again
okay we're fine okay oh boy another one
they're giving me so many chances they
really shouldn't I'm not I don't deserve
this in any way oh look another chance
oh good oh it's tons of chances oh it's
unlimited chances
hello hi what do I do about you okay oh
I know what I do
I got a oh I see it's one of these
things okay I gotta get you to press the
blue come on down everybody
oh god I'm shaking in my boots bliss I
was gonna take a while
come on come on I forgot
how did I forget that that was happening
how did I forget what was going on what
is wrong with me alright fine we're
gonna get through this all out naturale
[ __ ] and with oh god damn it mom
why did I say I was gonna get through
this au naturale
that means doesn't that mean that I'm
gonna do is naked and I don't think
that's what I want to do it's always
it's always the first try that I go
through these bad boys that things go
well for me and God is getting me bad is
[ __ ] chica it's okay I'm not yelling
at you I promise I promise I'm not I'm
doing very poorly on my life my life
choices and my life utilization I'm not
I'm not even halfway through I'm not
halfway through I gotta get halfway
through rusty I'm gonna go nowhere with
my life I can't do this I can't do this
I can't well I'm not saying I can't do
what's in front of me I can't do this
stupid playin that I'm doing this the
Beast stupidness that's that's what I'm
trying to actively avoid the Beast
stupid inge huh why am I such a stupid
why am I such a suck okay everything's
fine okay you think what's over here
is there anything no it's nothing okay
they're gonna give me another chance
after I get through here I just had to
get through to here and then eventually
they're gonna give me another chance
once I take my goddamn time with this
[ __ ] and you know enjoy life smell the
roses
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dude hey
Oh wasn't patient I know every time I do
this I get finicky and unpatient 'no
snis I get anti patient and it ends up
biting me in the chod I know
uh-huh Oh hehe haha what's up there
there's something up there I'm gonna
find it I'm gonna get it what's up here
oh it's a 1-up do I need this probably
not actually absolutely I do
considering my poor record of Mario
utilizations man 40-something clones
already down the windpipe something like
that I don't know okay this time I'm not
gonna be a suck about okay that's where
you're gonna be huh do it do something
do something no balls no balls no balls
yeah
no balls no balls won't do it again
we'll do it again whoa ah goddamn it
no balls the balls the balls I got no
balls cuz I got no room no balls the
balls the balls you got no balls huh you
don't come after me bruh no balls whoa
okay that's not where I expect you to go
Wow I'll take it
no balls the balls the balls won't do it
you won't do it you won't do it you
won't do it won't do it can't do it
we're gonna do nothing huh
aah whoo I did it Oh
okay I know what I need to do huh no
balls no balls no piranhas pants no
brought off [ __ ] god damn it
right at the last goddamn sec yes okay I
was right there if I did just done it
the first time around I would have been
way better off but I just sucked all
over it I sucked it so hard I just
sucked drink milk shake out of its balls
okay anyway movin on movin on movin on
movin on we got more to do we got more
to win that we had more things to do
I've totally forgotten that I've been on
camera this whole time so I don't know
what horrible horrible things I might
have said we're done oh god what is this
[ __ ]
what is this ass mess what is this ass
oh god I forgot that I don't pick him up
in this one okay so the objective is do
not touch as many of these as possible
[ __ ] I did exactly that I did exactly
the thing I was supposed to do but
there's a there's a mushroom in there
there's a checkpoint okay this is crazy
but I got it okay I don't know how I
stopped that ah damn it
dim damn dim down the flim-flam dimmed
and the flim-flam
god damn it with the dim damn the
flim-flam stop just stop stop oh okay
sick moves I'm gonna plan like I did
that on purpose [ __ ] again with this
[ __ ] oh don't rush no time to rush
what time to rush Oh God
will guess okay did that again oh [ __ ]
every time every goddamn time every
timtam time every Frick frack time yes
whoa
that was a [ __ ] that was a [ __ ]
whoo but I did it okay
I can do another I give me I can do one
more I can do one more man I bet the
world record is to someone going above
it all because I didn't go up I stayed
down on the ground floor where it was
safe so smb3 the mini-game cave oh boy
this doesn't sound good
oh I get it I gotta try to hit the POW
point I was easy got it
I like this if this is like this the
whole time boink
oh it's brick breaker someone made brick
breaker in this [ __ ] what the hell
that's so cool how in the hell did they
do that okay this is a welcome change
from everything else that was going on
this is awesome is so cool if I could
just hit it properly
hip-hip that's so cool that is so cool
so well made to like just a creative
idea I was what I've been watching the
game drums play Super Mario maker all
the time cuz I watch the game grumps
plate all the time anyway so it's
literally all I do but man that's so
cool
no oh wow they knew someone was gonna be
so stupid oh they knew oh they knew oh
thank goodness they knew am I supposed
to oh oh that's gonna be oh that's gonna
be impossible god damn it
oh that's gonna be impossible well how
oh I'm not supposed to be carrying this
I'll take this maybe if I knew this away
hey no just barely not enough but I
could probably get a head start
whoa huzzah huzzah huzzah huzzah who's a
smart man who's a smart man who's a
getting father knocked oh oh God
getting beaten in a back alley there we
go I'm so happy
Oh big boot of love oh this is perfect
hit hit what does that mean do I gotta
like ground oh yeah I forgot it can
ground stomp with this okay I can do
this smart idea
ah titties got time it on the top one
goddamnit go take a while oh no I just
barely goddamn it
I'll just smash my heel into the back
end of this take forever
ah that was right on target
oh come on I didn't even do anything
there it's totally passive goddammit why
can I only get one okay I got your
number now oh not so tough now not
standing so tall anymore
goddamnit just stomp down stomp down
damn it
stomp down damn it there we go Oh last
one are you gonna be a [ __ ] about it
you okay smash smash word how do I smash
Oh No
how do I do i oh ah oh when they barely
come to the top it's got to be like
perfectly timing there's calm there's
comments that said I got a stomp by the
there we go okay got it got it got it
comment said I got a stomp by the vines
to be able to get them right so hello
sorry - the winner goes the spoils here
get out of my way oh hello Bell are you
doing my supposed to stomp you okay that
was pretty easy thank you for playing I
guess
alright then goodbye it would sucked if
that killed me right at the end there
but it somehow figured Wow a checkpoint
holy hell there's a lot of minigames
here alright I'll take that thank you
oh that doesn't do that okay let's try
some of this
no up no up oh okay that makes more
sense okay I got it I got it so I'm
supposed to put it on and then bash this
guy around and it's gonna be doing son
he's got to get up on really nothing
goddamn it get up get up there we go
there we go okay so I just gotta get him
when he's being pushed over to the other
side yeah that's how it's done
oh [ __ ] come on come on that's probably
why I gave me a checkpoint just in case
god damn it the [ __ ] you man come on
da [ __ ] off it's always when I'm
underboss
[ __ ] off what the [ __ ] just get
no goddammit
[ __ ] you [ __ ] off man
there we go
it's gotta be the last one it's gotta be
the last one just gotta wave for the
last one and hope that the last one
comes not that was easy there we go done
done and done okay get those through and
let me get through my life I really hope
I don't have to do this one again you
guys goddammit Oh what is this
yes okay did it did it done it do is it
okay good bye thank you
okay I got 28 seconds come on we gotta
go go go go go go go go go go come on
too many minigames too many minigames
Kamandi mini-games oh god damn it what
is this
I need another checkpoint please god
dammit god dammit I can't that's not
helpful none of that is helpful what am
I supposed to do oh god no oh god no
what oh [ __ ]
time's up okay but times up apparently
but I'll start over at another
checkpoint this game is too long like
seriously it's just too long so thank
you everybody so much for watching I'll
pick this up in another episode real
soon but thanks again then hopefully
I'll get through this and as always I'll
see you oh what's that
Wow